welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
that got brain in the backseat like jfk
we're already off to a bad start so
there's no better time to talk about one
of the most dysfunctional families ever
put to film
that is the umbrella academy throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down everything we know so far
and what we've managed to gather from
interviews on the upcoming entry
this includes characters that are
returning what the plot could be
and a lot more obviously there's gonna
be heavy spoilers here so if you don't
want anything ruined
then turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel for character
breakdowns on the academy lineup
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the video without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into everything we know so far
okay so firstly the release date for
umbrella academy season 3
has not been announced yet normally
netflix shows take about a year to turn
around
and we typically expect to see seasons
released between 12 to 18 months after
their prior entry
however the pandemic has pretty much
pushed everything back
and it's unlikely that we'll be seeing
the third season before the mid point of
2021
with filming on shows slowly starting
again across the industry
and the script being near complete i
can't see the third season dropping
christmas 2021 at the earliest
netflix tend to put out production
information one month after the release
of a season
however with a lot of things still shut
down don't expect to see any updates
before september
so lots and lots of bad news but what
about this story and cast
well first the showrunner steve blackman
has dropped a number of notable things
about what could be happening
season two ended with the academy
returning home to find their father
and been alive however they had been
replaced by a new team
called the sparrow academy this was a
big wtf moment
but from interviews and materials that
we've had released after the reveal
there is a lot that we know when
discussing what the return of their
father meant for the group
blackman told tyler.com if you look
carefully
he's our har greaves but he looks a
little different it would be a good
guess that if we get another season
that they have the chance to work out
their issues they did try
in season two to some extent but
obviously that hard greaves do nothing
about them
and you know this hargreaves is an older
man but they have a chance to sort of
talk to him again
and hopefully they do better than they
did in season two
now this would not only delve deeper
into why hog reefs made the choices that
he did
but also what happened to the academy in
their youth
the younger years of the whole grief
siblings have been hinted at
but we've never had fully fleshed out
what the breaking point for them or was
from video interviews with the cast we
also know that there will be several
more easter eggs added that hint towards
the big twist on hargreaves
at present the academy don't know what
he really is but hopefully we get some
my parents are aliens inspired moments
that showcase what's
actually going on with the character and
what the mysterious scene towards the
end of season 10 really meant
blackman further went on to state trying
to understand their origin
is one of the themes that we're going to
address next year the first season was
meet the family
season two was get to know the family
season three is
who are we and where did we come from
what are we as superheroes
that is really a story i'd love to think
about more in season 3.
so it does look like we will be getting
a big focus on this aesthetic
and i think the question surrounding
superheroes does hint at other things
i actually reread the entire umbrella
academy run in the lead up to this video
and hotel oblivion deals with a lot of
superpowered criminals
running around after escaping the
titular hotel which was used as a prison
by hor griefs to hold them
i think that this will be reflected in
the world that we will see in season 3
and there will be a greater emphasis put
on the 43 children that were all born on
the same day in 1989.
throughout season 2 there were also
hidden 43 sparrows
and thus we can tell that the creative
team are putting a lot of thought into
this
justin h min who plays ben also stated
that season 3 will be the first time
that the academy have
really had to deal with people that have
supernatural abilities
outside of lila and vonia the group have
never fought a large number of
superhumans
and for season 3 they'll be going
toe-to-toe with other teams that have
these powers
so expected umbrella verse to sparrow
showdown at one point
with ben likely leading the charge now
we still know very little about the 43
beyond lila and the sparrows
and thus i think we will get to see what
happened to the children that weren't
adopted
after we discount all the characters we
know about we're left with 29
superpowered beings on the planet
that the show could definitely explore
so expect some big superhero showdowns
and a lot of cool characters going head
to head but what about lila herself
well it does seem like a certainty that
she will be returning
when discussing the character with
17.com blackman said the following
we're hopeful but i think lila's story
is definitely not finished yet
there's feelings between her and diego
and unfinished business with the family
she got a briefcase and got out but i
would say safely this is not the last we
saw of lila pitts
now it is possible that the time
briefcase could be the key to setting
things straight
but that all depends on whether lila
wants to help out or not
either way i think she was a great
addition to the roster of season 2
and i can't wait to see her back soon as
for the people who probably won't be
returning
i think pretty much that grace and pogo
will not be reappearing in the show
for a long long time during season two
diego had an interaction with grace
which eventually led to her discovering
hargreaves work with the majestic 12.
she took pogo with her and we didn't see
her again
now if you cast your mind back to season
one you may remember that the grace
robot was only created in order to take
care of bonye
after she killed the rest of her nannies
the fact that vonya wasn't at the
academy in this timeline
likely means that grace had no need to
be made and thus
i do think it's unlikely that we'll be
seeing her pop up again
unless it's the real one from the 60s
though at this point
she would probably be 90 herself now tom
hopper also stated that ben
may not even be called ben because he
was of course named by their mother
and if she's absent then this wouldn't
be the case
and thus he may have a totally different
name as the leader of the sparrow
academy
yep things could change that much now
i've already done a full video breaking
down the sparrows so
if you want to know more about them then
make sure you check it out after this
in summary though they're basically the
same as the current characters
and there's even a number one like
luther person who wasn't turned into an
ape
there's also a woman called caller who
similar to allison can bend reality with
a voice
and and a box guy a box guy
guy that's a box now in regards to what
they bring and what it means
for the overall show the cast actually
gave a lot away in an interview with
entertainment tonight
now we have to preface this interview by
saying that the umbrella academy
actually subscribes to the multi-world
time travel theory
similar to its use in end game this
states that when one travels back in
time
the person doing so actually creates
branch realities in which alternate
timelines play out
this was seen at several points
throughout the show namely at the
beginning of season 2
in which we saw an alternate timeline in
which america went to war with russia
and of course at the end of the season
when the group stepped into the sparrow
academy timeline
robert shien who plays klaus did confirm
that the group were actually in an
alternate universe
and that the next season will discuss
how multiple versions of the timeline
exist
i definitely recommend that you check
out the entire interview as it goes
massively into depth into the idea of
the shattered glass theory
which is also brought up as well that
states that the universe works similar
to the shattering of glass
according to the theory when a big event
happens it's meant to shatter the
universe and create multiple branching
timelines
and expand away from the original and
the academy have likely found themselves
in a version of this
in which they were not adopted by hog
reefs this could lead to the group
potentially jumping from timeline to
timeline
in the hopes that the next jump will be
the one that finally takes them
home so it's likely they're going to
have to deal with the repercussions left
behind by introducing superpowered
beings
into the world back in the 60s through
holland and this brand new timeline
may be a worse one than the one that
they escaped from
though i doubt it because the apocalypse
happened but
meh still still better than the 2020
that we actually got now there's still a
lot of things that could happen
but in conclusion lila will be back and
she'll be getting explored in more
detail
we are also dealing with alternate
realities and maybe getting more time
travel focused elements
it's unlikely that we'll be seeing grace
again but who knows
if we're exploring hargreaves's past
then she may pop up there
we also know for definite that we're
gonna be having one hell of an adventure
with the academy
another show might not return for a long
time there's still a lot of things to
look forward to
anyway that's our full breakdown of
everything we know so far about the
third season
i'd obviously love to hear what you
think is going on
and also what you hope to see in it if
you enjoyed this video then don't forget
to check out all our breakdowns on the
show
including a deep dive into hargreaves's
origin story
and who the sparrows are we're also
giving away a free copy of the avengers
on any console of your choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of august so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you